twas the night before Christmas and all
through the borough the children were
snuggled their presents wrapped thorough
but this tales not about presents or
Santa or ponies it's about three dudes
three bros 3 ride or die homies
gentleman 14 years ago to this very
night I lost my parents you guys have
been with me every single Christmas
since then you knew but tonight we have
decided to end this tradition Kris is
just too [ __ ] famous saying I was
saying more and I think about to have a
baby this is for you yeah and ain't
nothing to [ __ ] with who say Clan ain't
nothing okay okay they can they can hear
that you have been such a rock
throughout this whole pregnancy
you're like my Dwayne Johnson thank you
can I just focus on yourself holy [ __ ]
truce
just okay everything cocaine for 11
years I don't think no one has I don't
very far I have a present for you we're
going to the best Christmas party in New
York City so that gives us several hours
to hit as many traditions as possible
to the end of an era I think the cocaine
the mushrooms are reacting poorly are
you gonna be cool at this party cool
spook gee you look insane only your
right eye is working by the weirdo yes
you look weird
still weird weird
are you guys mister singing Miley Cyrus
she destroyed wrecking ball you still
like that so everybody does
you can cry to it you can run to it yeah
I can party to it timeless
I'm gonna be honest I'm freaking out
about having the baby I'm supposed to be
a rock but I'm not a rock how fast are
you right now
hallelu not that kind of church no oh
Jesus that would they think we did do it
yeah
can they tell I'm Jewish yes you [ __ ]
sweater don't you dare throw up in here
swallow it like a girl would I need a
barf bag barking oh it's so happy it's
so happening alone Jesus uh I've been
having pretty crazy night I'm gonna
level with you a little fox
right now you have gags oh how I love
you
oh this waria I provide the blood bank
leg